hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to cheatin hitman oh don't
believe his lies that's a reference in a
deep winter night spent entirely
streaming Dark Souls Nick Bracken
professional hitman for hire
contemplates his existence God what have
I been doing with my life I wanted to
become a creator not a murderer this is
my life now I am ruined
but then internalization 100% as he
finally beats Dark Souls a glimmer of
hope crosses Nick's face or is it maybe
there's still some time to change maybe
I could become a cheating hitman I don't
know what that means
what's the matter with you from agency
you've barely taken any job for weeks
get back to work you be terminated
sincerely the agency also happy holidays
[Music]
objectives just shoot the target drop
the body in the lake make sure he bleeds
in the morning what the hell this may
sound weird but I'm a hit man and I'm
trying to save your life you a hit man
sounds like you need to reread your job
description you're lucky I'm not in the
mood for killing here's what we'll do
instead okay so let me get this straight
you want me to help you stage my own
death so that your client believes I'm
actually dead correct to do that first
you need to create a believable setting
right I'll set up the backdrop some
props and the lighting shouldn't I pose
somewhere don't worry about it I'll tell
you what to do what about makeup and
fake blood please I'm not an amateur
it's all taken care of and then once
everything's set up you'll get a good
angle to take a photo of my body and
send it to your client exactly you okay
with that actually yes I'm in a bit of a
model not that it's any of your business
so yeah sounds fantastic what are we
shooting with God what
Oh Oh okay drop the body by the lake
make sure he bleeds shoot the target oh
right in the middle of his goddamn face
oh [ __ ] okay we need blood Lao okay
he's very bloody bleh [ __ ] lights
morning lights oh oh and pose oh Jesus
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry oh jeez oh God
oh I'm sorry sorry okay you'll just epic
oh okay all right
let's drop you down well that was Oh God
okay back that's that's good oh Jesus
oh I'm so sorry man I mean I know I was
originally supposed to kill you but how
do i how do I make him fall down oh boy
I'm gonna move you and a ditch by the
leg oh that's hilarious you move you're
right in the lake nope by the lake let
me pose you again oh oh all right right
about right about there okay that's good
okay he's back he's by the lake oh man I
talked to him so tell me a little about
yourself
hey now that I got you covered in blood
and full of bullet wounds tell me about
yourself don't know don't you care who
you're supposed to kill I prefer not to
so you're a bit of a wuss is what you're
saying I'm starting to see why someone
would want to kill you what was that
nothing I definitely heard something
well good enough I guess okay all right
well let me oh oh but this isn't a very
believable backdrop but you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm just roll with it
blam okay sharing the photo can't even
see my face oh I need to see the face
need to see the freaking bullet wound
okay he just happens to be sitting up
with these do oh my god hi hello you
doing your morning yoga
oh good get those abductor muscles
working it's good for you hi okay any
problems with this one cuz I don't have
a problem saying the photo
look too bad for an amateur so what do I
do now give advice hey I'm not in the
charity business here I'm gonna give you
advice why were you I'd leave the
country what you're gonna kill me nice
done overall here's some thoughts sweet
kill just what I was looking for the
setting felt a little off so much blood
mmm looks like morning lovely you know
what you're doing and we are loving it
join the cheatin assassin's Association
today to receive feedback for your work
and win big prizes and awards every week
all right tom objective drowned the
target doing in a forest no props with
less than two stars that is so bizarre
my brave I'm here to help you you're at
wait I know you
yeah you're that guy for the podcast
that what are you talking about no I'm
not Nick girl has Dark Souls finally
driven you insane just do as I say okay
so I got to drown the target how the
[ __ ] am I gonna drown the target so I
need to drown a mom Oh
oh I could have made it look more
realistic
oh okay so how do I drown you oh I gotta
make him blue we're gonna make him nice
and blue this guy is so drowned this
guy's so drowned gonna make it look more
realistic we can't just do this I get
trees in it look at all the trees look
at all the identical plastic trees you
can barely see them through the foliage
get a nice river running through here
flap right there that's good yeah yeah
that's good
I think Knights good all right you hey
pose sorry uh how do I do this oh I get
I know how I do this you're an airplane
bye spine
and their God okay
nailed it okay good yeah that's good
yeah just hold that post midair that's
good I'm dead in a ball oh I get it
oh he's stuck in the oh okay okay you
know what this is this is pretty good
it's pretty good that's beyond esteem
dad I don't know why there's a tree in
the middle of the river but I don't
think they're gonna question it so send
that off I was satisfied with your work
here's some thoughts sweet kill just
what I was looking for everything about
the setting felt right well I'm glad I
could make anonymous feel content about
the kill thanks for your submission
overall we give your rating a 50% try to
use a variety of props don't use the
same prop too often I might be wrong but
I'm pretty sure I saw the model I asked
you to kill at the airport way what are
you talking about objective use poison
drop the body in an alley in the middle
of the night ask her it'd break his
bones too
oh god it's a little bit vicious don't
you think come on not again I told you
to leave the country not might befall
people want to kill me isn't it
let's just get this over with I gotta
use poison how the [ __ ] do I use poison
oh oh oh he's gonna be a real sick okay
so I need a prop of some sort
yeah maybe mushrooms no that wouldn't be
right
it's got to be in the middle of the
night that's for damn sure no that's
wrong gotta get a backdrop of an
alleyway oh I gotta break your bones
your buddy I'm sorry all right wait no
okay that's good dere that's good excuse
me while I break your bones oh Jesus
that's about right right there Rach
Snapple pop yep that Brigid so I gotta I
need a dumpster I need a sweet
dumpster bro sweet dump all right that's
good trash can
good nice okay let's try this
I mean it's kind of an alleyway isn't it
a little bit right that's good enough
for me well that's definitely an
improvement over the first one looks
like I'm definitely getting the hang of
this maybe we could do this again
sometime leave now
Yeah right see you soon thanks for your
submission overall we'd give you a
rating zero
don't use too few props try to use a
variety kind of hit man are you are you
kidding me this photo is no proof
alrighty then well they're suspicious
that's not good thanks for playing and
actually making this far that's all the
content we got oh that's pretty cool I
mean at first I was very confused at
first I was really unbelievably confused
I had no idea what was going on but as I
got into it I was like I could actually
see this being a thing it's it's it's
like a little creative enjoyment thing I
don't know what it is you're not
murdering people which is kind of fun I
mean there's there's a lot to this I
mean it obviously it's unpolished and
there's not a lot of variety there's no
music there's very little sound effects
but from what you've got
you could have quite an interesting game
here I've never seen a game quite like
this one so it's interesting to see
these new and creative ideas so anyway
that's all the time I got for this
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to try to do better
than I did you can check out the game
through the description below and send
the developer some support you know
these new ideas needs a lot of
encouragement to make sure that they
come about and you know I wouldn't mind
seeing more of this so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]